in this course you will improve your
command line skills your Linux skills
and your hacker skills this course is a
walkthrough of the abandoned war game
from Over the wire it's very similar to
a CTF which is a type of security
competition where participants attempt
to solve challenges on their computers
to earn points sabiasachi will guide you
through a series of security challenges
involving the Linux shell remote
connections and SSH consider trying to
solve each challenge yourself first
today we are going to see the
walkthrough of this Bandit over the wire
war game so in the internet I came
across this particular website that is
over the wire and they were having
certain challenges out there so if I
take you to this over the wire main
website so we have got several war games
that we will surely for in the next
videos I'll be covering so today I will
be covering about this Bandit and what I
have found in this particular challenge
is on on this particular game it's the
kind of a CTF thing that we will be
receiving Flags in each and every stages
of this game and this particular game or
this particular war game is very good
for the newbies or for the people who
are just starting out and are not so
much familiar with the Linux terminal so
if you actually play this game you will
be much more efficient or your skills in
using the Linux terminal will increase
so today we are gonna learn Linux by
solving this particular challenges and
this particular challenge war games
so I am assuming that you are having
some basic ideas some basic knowledge of
the Linux terminal commands like what is
mkdir what is LS what is RM what is what
is cat
what is nano all these things so let's
get ahead and let's start solving the
challenges one by one so first what I'll
do is I am inside my folder OTW and I'm
gonna make a directory null as Bandit
so let me get inside it
and level 0 says that the goal for this
level is for you to log into the game
using SSH so we are going to use SSH but
I will be using SSH pass minus p and
here goes the password and SSH
and they have said that the host to
which you need to connect is bandit.labs
over the wire.org so
bandit.labs dot over the wire.org
and the username is bandwidth 0
so the username is Bandit 0
and the port is
the password is when it's 0 and once you
log in go to level one the port is
triple to zero so minus P triple to zero
because SSH runs by default on Port 22.
so this is all about it and before that
they have said that the password is
banded zero so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to write Bandit 0 and save it on a
file named 0 and I'm going to do some
command substitution over here and I'm
going to write CAD zero
so basically what I'm doing is I am
making a file called as 0 and inside
that file the password of every level
will be stored like I'll be making
different files and on different files
level of the password will be stored and
I'm using SSH pass I am providing the
password using command substitution so
cad0 will
give us output as bandwidth 0 and Bandit
0 will be supplied to this switch minus
P which stands for password in SSH pass
and then we are telling SSH to connect
to this particular host
as the user Bandits 0 in the port triple
to zero so let's hit enter and let's
solve Bandit
so let's go to the next level they say
that the password for the next level is
stored in a file called readme so clear
LS we got a readme file over here and if
I do cat read me hit enter we get the
password for the next level out there
let's say use this password to log into
Bandit 1 using SSH whenever you find a
password for a level use SSH to log into
that level and continue the game so for
them it is that in each level we will be
getting the password as the flag and
that password will help us log into the
next level so this is the password of
bandwidth one
so let's exit and
Echo
the password to one and let's use
SSH pass
cat one and let's switch the user to one
in level one we have got that the
password for the next level is stored in
a file called minus
let's go ahead and let's see we have got
a file called as minus so it's a special
character file so to
see the special character file we have
to use a syntax that is dot slash minus
and hit enter and we will be able to see
this particular file if I do not use
this dot slash
thing and if I simply give minus so this
means that bash is taking this that I
will be giving some character which will
be treated as some kind of switch for
the cat command but this is not the case
we want to specify that minus is my
final name so for that we are giving dot
slash and hence we have received the
password for the next level
two
let's save that
and let's switch to Bandit 2
they say that the password for the next
level is stored in the file spaces in
the file name located in the home
directory
so if you wonder that these are four
separated files then you are probably
wrong because if I do LS minus L A you
can see it's a continuous file like it
is single file having spaces in its file
name
so the way we can write is that is cat
spaces backslash
space in
this
file and this is the actual way how we
write
or how we include space
in the script this is known as escape
sequence
and we will simply copy it and if I do
not give this backslash what will happen
is
if I give it like this this will be
treated as four separate file names so
cat spaces cat in cat this and Cat file
name this will be treated like this
manner but we do not want that
we want to specify or we want to say to
the bash script that include this
particular spaces into a single file so
the way we say that by including this
backslash
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so in level three the password for the
next level is stored in a hidden file in
the in here directory
so we have got our directory over here
CD in here
so if I do LS
we have you can see nothing over here so
LS minus L A will show us that there is
a file called as hidden or we can also
do
LS minus a which will list all the files
minus a stands for all probably
I use it I'm all so
dot hidden so I will be using cat dot
hidden and simply we will be receiving
the file or receiving the flag which is
a password for the next level
foreign
[Music]
let's switch to level four
level four
states that the password for the next
level is stored in your human readable
file in the in here directory
okay
so CD in here LS we have got several
files
so cat minus file 0 0
okay I did a mistake
I have to specify dot slash minus file
zero zero because it is starting with a
special character which I said in my
first
challenge
so we have got some content which I do
not need to see
they say it is present in a human
readable file so we have to check for
the file type and the way we do it using
the file command so file then dot slash
minus file zero zero so they will say
that it's an open PJP public key
we can say 0 1 it's a data file 0 2 it's
a data file and likewise we can go till
0 9 to see which type of file all the
files are but this is the kind of
monotonous work so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use a bash script by
using a for Loop so for i n then using a
command substitution LS
do
file dot slash dollar I
tan
so what this is going to do is I is a
variable so I in LS LS will list all
these files and on each iteration on
each iteration every file name will be
stored inside this variable I and I am
saying that on each iteration do file
dot slash file name so this will result
in giving us all the file types for each
and every file present in the current
directory so we can see that file 7 is
of ASCII text
if you don't know what ask stands for
ASCII stands for American Standard code
for information interchange
let me cut it out get file I mean minus
file
zero seven and we have received the
password for our next
level
let's save it as five
and let's login into Blended five
[Music]
this game is easy till now let's see
what we can see in the next level when
it level 5 says the password for the
next level is stored somewhere under the
in here directory so let's go to in here
directory we have got several folders
out here
so let me do LS minus r to get a
recursive view of what files are present
inside each folder are means recursive
so I'm going to list all the files
recursively so there are tons of files
over here I'm going to do LS minus r l
hopefully that will work
and yes this is
showing us the data of each and every
file
and the more better way if I do LS minus
a r l or a l r whatever you write a
stands for all L stands for a detailed
list and R stands for recursively
I will get to save all the hidden files
all the folders each and everything
and they say that we have to find for
the file which is human readable 103
device inside then it is not executable
at all so one thing we can do is this is
the file size these are the pile size so
we can manually go and search for the
files as one zero three three byte and
manually go ahead and run the file
command to see whether it is humanitable
or not but we do not have to do so much
of
things but there is a tool called as
find so find dot dot Min search in the
current directory so find the command
I'm telling fine to search in the
current directory
which is human readable whose size is
one zero three three bytes C is a suffix
that we need to give in find a command
which states that
C stands for bytes
so 1033 bytes and it is not executable
so not operator and executable
Q table so this is the whole command let
me explain you the thing find dot find
dot win search in the current directory
and search for a file which is human
readable whose size is one zero three
three c c is a suffix that we use to
represent byte and which is not
executable so not is an operator and we
are stating executable so so it is not
executable and if I hit enter
I'll be getting the file name right over
here and if I simply do cat we can see
or we will be getting the password for
our next level
[Music]
let's go to level six
level six says the password for the next
level is stored somewhere on the server
so find slash because it is stored
somewhere on the server slash main
search on The Parent Directory or in the
root directory and has all the following
properties let's see what the following
properties first property is owned by
user band 7 so minus user Bandit 7.
owned by group Bandit 6 so
minus group
Bandit 6.
and it is 33 byte in size so minus size
33c
if I hit enter
we get to see lots of permission denied
messages
interesting
we shouldn't be seeing these messages
right over here we can see that there's
a file which is not showing us
permission denied these are some
messages that have been shown to us but
this file is not showing us any message
and it is stating when it's 7 or
password so what we can do is we can
redirect all these messages into the
garbage bin so the way we do it
is if I just write over here to
and redirect all the problematic
messages to a Dustbin present in Linux
called as Dev null to represent all the
problems all the messages that are not
our usage all the errors and all so it
will be redirected in this Dev slash
null and we can see the only file that
is not shown any error or so
we'll be copying it get the file name
and we will be receiving the password
for the next level
foreign
[Music]
let's switch to Bandit 7.
and I am storing my passwords locally in
my local machine so that in case my
connection breaks I can log in directly
so level 7 says that the password for
the next level is stored in a file
later.txt next to the word million so LS
we have got data.txt WC minus l
later txt gives us that there there are
98 5067 lines if you are wondering what
this means what WC stands for word count
and minus L is a switch which stands for
that count the number of lines present
in this particular file so data.txt is
having ninety eight thousand five
minutes seven line and out of those
lines I have to find the word millionth
next to which my password for the next
level is present so I'll be doing cat
data.txt and I will be redirecting its
output or I will be sending its output
to a tool called as graph which is pre
pre-installed in Linux
shell so grab and search for the word
millionth
so if I do so grep will take the output
of cat data.txt and we'll search for the
word millionth in that output and we
have received the password as stated it
is next to the word millionth
so let's exit out of it and let's do a
go
eight and let's switch to user 8.
grab is actually used to search a word
and let's see what's level 8 as for us
the password for the next level is
stored in a 50 or txt and is the only
line of text that occurs only once all
right so probably there's zero txt and
wc minus L that it takes either only one
thousand and one line so if I dare to do
cat data.txt my whole terminal will be
full of text and these are all the
random passwords which they have said
that has been repeated several number of
times so beforehand what I'll do is I'll
be sorting them in ascending order so
salt
so this is sorted and we can see that
each password or each string has been
repeated several number of times so I do
not want repeated text I want unique
text so unique
so only
these text will be shown to me that are
unique and they're repeated strings will
not be shown but I want to know how many
times this or how many times each string
has been repeated
so for that I will be using unique minus
C minus C stands for count so each line
has been repeated 10 times and they have
said that it is the only line that
occurs only once so we have got a line
that occurs only one so this is the
provable password that we are searching
for
and one more thing we can do is we can
use rep minus V10 minus V is stands for
actually grep is used to search for a
particular word from a file minus V is
used to tell grep that do not search for
that word and give us the output except
that word so I will be getting the
output except the word 10 that is not
present so if I do not use this grip
command so what I will be getting that
all the files all the strings having the
number or the string 10 in them but if I
use minus V I'll not be getting all this
and I'll be getting only the line that
is not containing any 10 so this is the
line
so that's great
let's save it in nine
and let's login to Bandit
9 and let's see what do we have in level
nine
the password for the next level is
stored in a file error.txt in one of the
few human readable strings preceded by
several equal to characters
so it seems that it is not a human
readable string or even a double file
it's a data file so if I dare to print
the
file so we have got or we have received
a binary file that's great
let's do clear I will be using the
strings commands strings is used to show
us the human readable strings out of a
binary or out of a gibberish file so cat
data.txt so whichever file has any
readable strings or human readable
strings are present that will be shown
to us and they have said that the
password is preceded by several equal
to's so the password is starting with
several equal to so grep equals
so we can find that this is the password
because it is starting with several
equal to every line has equal to but not
starting with several equal to but these
lines are starting with several equal to
and it's stating that the password is
this and
like this is the password out of
intuition
so
[Music]
let's save it as 10.
yep
let's use SSH pass once again let's
switch to the user from Bandit 9 to
Bandit 10 and quickly see what's present
for us in Bandit level 10. the password
for the next level is stored in the file
letter.txt which contains base64 encoded
data okay so it's encoded data that we
have received that is base 64.
uh I have done a mistake
cat data.txt
so it is a base sensitive base64 encoded
data and the way you can recognize that
it is ending with two equal to
so not an issue cat data.txt and we will
be sending the output to a tool called
as base64 it is installed by default and
minus D for decode and we will be
receiving the password where 64 is
already installed in linuxil especially
in Ubuntu you can already get it and you
don't know about other Linux distros
so let's save it
paste it in 11. and if you're wondering
how I know all these commands and all of
course I'll be I have been using Linux
for so many years but the way you can
remember all the switch is number one
practice and number two by visiting
their manual and by seeing what are the
switches and what else you can do with
the command
if you're not aware how to do that let
me show you
so let's first go to band 11 and let
let's see what is there
the password for the next level is
stored in a file error txt where all
lower customer status have been rotated
by 13 position okay so LS txt now you
might have seen me to use switches like
LS minus L LS minus a l a l s minus a LS
minus r how can I do so right
because I have been using a command that
is man man stands for manual and manual
LS man LS this will show me all the
things all the commands all the switches
that I can actually use
or that is actually present for a
particular command so if I use the arrow
keys to navigate around the manual you
can go ahead and read all the switches
and use it and practice it in your
day-to-day life so you can see that I
have been using capital r in my previous
challenges so it was for recursive there
has been many several different things
as well you can see L for long listing
format
so this is how we use it and you can use
minus Cube to quit it with the manual
and this is how I remember all the
switches so no worries if you actually
forgot some switch you can go ahead and
type man then the following command that
you are not aware of
from then you can go ahead and read
about that particular command
so enough of talk we have got data txt
cat del.txt
it is Rod 13 encoded so it has so each
alphabet has been rotated at 13 13th
number of times not 13 times I would say
it has been rotated at the 13th number
what I'm actually trying to mean that if
I say Route 13 I'll go
hopefully by seeing the image you can
understand this is raw 13 I'll go
a is represented at n b s o c s p d s q
and vice versa so g u r
so G for t u for H and R for E so it's t
h e so it's the and probably it would be
password is and then some random
password
so I'll be copying it
and let's go
to all
raw 13 and I will go into this website
awesome website.com you can select your
Rod algorithms rotation algorithms dots
Transportation so they have used route
13. I'll be pasting it and they'll be
showing us the correct that decoded
string will be shown to us D code is the
correct word that I can use
so
exit and let me save the password
in 12
let's go and mess with level 12.
level 12 says that the password for the
next level is stored in a file data.txt
let's go ahead and switch to Bandit 12.
until then I'll be having some water
which that is the password for the next
level that is stored in the file letter
txt which is a hex term of a file that
has been repeatedly compressed for this
level it may be useful to create a
directory and the temp in which you can
work using mqdr for example this and
that okay so we have to do a lots of
you want to say extraction and
decompression all those things
so if I do LS 0.txt and the cat data.txt
okay
this is a hex dump if you're saying a
hex dump for the first time so welcome
or congratulations you have
seen a hex done for the first time so
let's see what we can do with that
before that let me make a directory in
the temp folder because I don't think
that I am having permission over here to
make a directory
mkdir for example what to say
now permission day night very good
CD TMP can I make a folder over here
oh
file exist seriously who made it
great
I mean of course many people are using
the same server and I am not the only
person having the the only names of
Versace
okay
mkdir
what to say
game okay
so game which does not exist let's see
the game
let's copy the data.txt into that game
folder
I mean let's go to the game
and great so we are having this file
over here now let's cut
data.txt and give it to xxd minus r x x
d is a tool that is used to generate as
well as reverse or hex dump so minus r
stands for reverse
so if I hit enter we can see all those
of stuff some binary stuff probably
let's do clear and let's save this file
into another files for example
hex dump
if I clear it out if I do LS we can see
two files there are txt and hex dump and
if I do file hex them you can see it's a
gzip compressed data if you're not aware
what gzip is in Windows we are having
raw in Windows we are having zip files
similarly in Linux we are having gzip
so I will be renaming this hex dump into
hexdump dot gz which is the extension of
gzip file and I will be using gzip to
decompress this GC file so remember I
have
renamed or changed the term the name of
the file hex dump to hexdump.gz and now
hexdump doesn't exist so if I just show
you LS you can see
hexdump.gz exist now I will be doing
gzip minus d g zip is a tool that is
used to decompress or compress
files so gzip minus D and then
hexdump.gz
if I do LS we can see that this file has
extracted another file called as hexdump
and let's see what is the file type of
that particular hex Dom file so it's a b
zip to compress data which is kind of
similar to gzip as well
so I'll be renaming it to bz2 Y2 because
they have used bzip 2 so its extension
is bz2
if I do LS you can see
hexdump.bz to exist
so B Z 2 I mean B zip2 minus D hex dump
dot bz2 so they have produced hex dump
it has produced hex them
until hex dump again a gz file so MV
X damp
X dump dot gz again gzip minus D oops
sorry G is f minus
minus d
they've extracted hex dump again
now it's a tar archive you can see it's
a four six star archive
I will be using tar minus x v
x v f as we have actually means or you
can write is x v f like this as well X
stands for extract v stands for verbose
and of f stands for file so what I've
got I've got probably hex
I forgot the file name exam
so tar minus x v f
then X dump
so verbose will actually tell me that
what file or files this tar archive has
been has extracted for us so it has
extracted data Five Dot bin for us
so let's see while data 5 dot bin
archive again
so this time data 5 dot bin
it has extracted at a six dot win
let's see what is the file type of data
6.bin it's a b zip2
so MV data 6 dot bin into Data 6 dot bin
Dot bz2
if you can understand what I am doing
I am actually renaming the extracted
output since it's a busy to compress
data I have just changed the extension
and visit to minus d
and then it has extracted for us data 6
dot bin once again
and how did I know that because I have
already changed the name data 6.pin into
Data 6.pin.bz2
so let's see
what out what type of file it is it is a
tar archive again so
let's go
data set start bin right
it has extracted data a DOT win right
data 8 dot bin it's a gzip file again so
MV
data 8 dot bin to data 8 dot bin dot gz
and gzip minus D Delta 8 dot win.gz we
have received data 8.bin once again
so file data 8 dot win it's an ASCII
text
so let's write cat data8.bin and here is
the password the password is this for
our next level
so
it is 13.
foreign
we have got the the password for the
next level is stored in HC Bandit pass
when it 14 and can only be read by user
when it 14 for this level you do not get
the next password but you get a private
SSH key that can be used to log into the
next level great
foreign
key.private okay
so we are going to use this private key
to login into SSH or login into bandage
14 using SSH so I'll be using SSH
magnet 14
and since we are logging in using in
like inside the Bandit server itself so
we will be using localhost and also they
have noted that localhost is a host Slim
minus p is triple to 0 for sure and we
are giving an identifier that we do not
have the password but we do have a
private key so use this private key to
identify me as Bandit 14.
so it's asking for permission I'm giving
it yes and we are inside
Bandit 14.
a quick who am I you can see Bandit 14
and I will be navigating into the HC
folder where there's a folder colors
when it pass and I will be extracting
the password for Bandit 14.
so I have done so let's open another
shell over here real quick
OTW Bandit over here present all the
passwords Echo this
to 14.
let's see what challenges we have in 14
the password for the next level can be
retrieved by summary in the password the
current level on Port 30 000 on
localhost
okay so the password for the next level
can be retrieved by submitting the
password of the current level so we have
to submit the password of the current
level on the
host localhost and on the port 30 000.
so we will be using Netcare for that
netcat is a Swiss army knife Swiss Army
tool sorry Swiss Army tool which is used
to make a TCP UDP connection between
systems which and also used to listen
for ports
so you will be understanding when I'm
trying to say or rather if you go to man
and see you can see it's an arbitrary
tcpdp connection that listens you can
see all the descriptions you can pause
the video and read it
so NC and I'm connecting on localhost on
Port 30
000 and it is asking me for the password
of the current level see if I provide
the password and hit enter I will be
getting the password of the next level
and let me close it
for the next level so if I hit exit and
exit
Echo
store it as 15 and let's go to Bandit
15.
so straight away from 14 from 13 we have
we are going to Bandit 15
that's great let's go to bandage 15 the
password for the next level can be
retrieved by 7 in the password the
current level of
2.301 on localhost using SSL encryption
so in netcat we were using HTTP or
normal
connection clear text protocol but here
we will be using https that is SSL
encryption SSL stands for secure socket
layer
so for that we'll be using a tool called
as open SSL actually I haven't been
using a tool for so long so I kind of
forgot what is the format so probably
it's open SSL as client
minus connect
localhost is the host name and I think I
have to give the port name like this
3001 and then I have to give the
password
so
before that let me
write
pass is equals to probably have saved
the password yeah
so it's saying read our block like this
is the output of
but then if you're confused what
actually happened let me close the
connection let me clear it let me save
the password in a particular
variable so that I don't forget
now I'll be using open SSL I will be
telling that my client
is with whom I want to connect is
localhost
and the port I want to connect is 3000
3001 if I hit enter it will show me all
the messages that
connected can't use a cell get server
name or servers some headers some
certificates
some more information some handshakes
and all some hex terms again so we are
not really interested and you can see
there's a prompt that is waiting for us
to give the password
so I'll paste the password over here and
if I hit enter it says correct and gives
us
new password if you could see this block
right over here
so I have given the password of this
level that is banded 15 and we have
received the password of Bandit 16.
so let's copy it
great
let's connect to bandage 16 real quick
[Music]
the credentials for the next level can
be retrieved by submitting the password
the current level to a port on localhost
in the range 31 000 to 32 000 first find
out which of the sports have a server
listening on them then find out which of
this speaks SSL and which don't so there
is only one server that will give them
exponentials the other will simply send
back to you whatever you send to it
so we have to do some port scan and some
network enumerations over here it's the
best tool I can only find that
in my Arsenal or in my tool okay that is
nmap
so nmap scan the localhost from the port
range 31 to 32 000.
so nmap has said that these are the
pores that are open
so I'll be telling n Maps Okay and map
to do one more favor scan the Local Host
in the given Port of mine only scan
localhost on the given Port that is
three one zero four six
three one five one eight
three one six nine one
three one seven nine zero and three one
nine six zero so do not search anything
beyond this mentioned Port because you
will be taking much more time so I have
specified only the ports that you gonna
scan for and I want to know the service
versions
of each and every port each and every
port is running some services so I want
to know all the service versions and the
time that you are going to use is 4 so
the greater the number the greater speed
it is going to reach so it it is like in
nmap I am probably not sure the T value
is ranging from zero to five so zero is
uh slow and five is fastest
so I use D4
so I'm telling nvab the scan the
localhost for these ports and tell me
what are the service versions are
running hopefully from the explanation
you have understood and of course it is
going to take a lot amount of time
so let's see so out of all the given
ports we will be
we have to find which Port speaks SSL or
which Port has SSL service running on
so we have to
uh what to say separate those
and there is only one server that will
give us the next credential and other
will send back to you whatever you send
to it
okay so probably I have to give the
password okay here they say that can be
retrieved by submitting the password of
the current level so I have to submit
the password of level 16 to one of those
ports
using open SSL because they have said
that it is using open SSL now if I use
the up Arrow key
in the terminal right here so I'll be
able to understand that only 80 percent
done and 14 seconds remaining so let it
do the scan
okay we have got
lots of data 100 done okay
nmaps can report
these are the pores that are open these
are some
uh what to say some responses
so the ports that are open are
this one three one five one eight and
three one seven nine zero
so
I'll be doing
open SSL
s client
minus connect and where before that
cat HC
when it pass when it's 16 let me save
the password real quick let me copy the
password brother what I can do is simply
I can do X clip over here
not installed
not a problem what x clip does is this
clip will basically
uh take this particular output and we'll
save it in my clipboard so I do not have
to copy it once again no problem
I have copied it and let's
deals openssl so open SSL
as underscore client minus connect
localhost
on the port the first Port is three one
five one eight and it says Echo
so let's see three one five one eight
gut feeling says that it will probably
gives us the output that we are
providing it
if I say the password
yeah this was that server which they say
that others will simply send back to you
whatever you send it so if I say
hello
how are you
I am fine
subscribe
to my channel and all sorts of things
Channel
so this is not the board that we are
interested in there was one more port
that is
31790 let's see
so instead of this 31790 let's hit enter
and let's paste the password
and okay so we have received correct and
we have received a RSA private key file
so let's copy it Ctrl shift C
let's go to Temp folder and
make a directory called game it exists
one two okay CD game
one two
and let me make a copy of it so Nano
RSA file
and I'll be pasting the certificate over
here or the certify the private key
and I'll save it so there's my rsf file
and it is currently having permissions
that all people can at least read it the
user who has created the file can
actually rewrite it doesn't matter
groups can read write it which matters
and other people the whole world can
read it private key needs to be very
very secret private key is not for
everyone to share
so we have to change the permission so
I'll be using chmod
this change mode Maybe
600 what does 600 means that 4 stands
for read 2 stands for right and one
stands for execute so 6 means that for
this user for user
six wins read and write only so like
it's four and two so read write 0 means
nothing for groups and 0 means nothing
for rest of the people
hopefully that makes sense
so if I do LS minus l a right now you
can see that only I am having read write
permissions read write as I said read
stands for four and right is 2 so 4 plus
2 is the 6 so that's why 6 and everybody
is having 0 and now I will be using SSH
so SSH
minus I RSA file
Bandit 17 at the rate
localhost minus p2220
yes and we are inside Bandit 17.
who am I we are Bandit 17 let's go to
Bandit 17 and
I've done a big mistake by removing the
thing I would have saved the Bandit 17
password anyways another password at
least
probably what I can do is get HC
Bandit pass and Bandit 17.
all right this is the password
in case my connection is lost I can
actually
log into bandage seven is in this
password
when it level 17 says
there are two files in the home
directory passwords.old let's see LS
password.new password.ol yes and the
password for the next level is in
password.new and is the only line that
has been changed between password.ol and
password.new okay
so what this says that there are two
files password.org so there is an old
password file and a new password file
the content of old password file has
been duplicated into password.new file
except one particular line and we have
to find that line which actually
contains the password of the Bandit 18
user so for that we will be using a
command called as diff
let me just dip
then password dot old
bus word dot new
div command will give us the difference
between password.ol and password at new
and which line has been changed and
which line has been added
so this line has been removed and this
line has been added
so I will be copying this line which is
the password for Bandit 18.
let's exit and Echo
foreign
and
did I do a mistake oh we are in band 16.
sorry I thought I was in my route
directory
let's save it
thank God I cross checked it anyways in
Bandit 18 we have got
or in minute 70 we have what
Okay so
we have solved it
let's go to Bandit 18 first of all
okay so whenever we're trying to log in
it says bye bye connection to
bandit.labs over the wire.org is closed
and they have given a note if you solve
this level and see bye bye when trying
to log into Bandit 18 this is related to
Next Level that is Bandit 19.
so of course we're gonna go to level 18
the password for the next level is
stored in a file read me in the home
directory unfortunately someone has
modified the dot bash RC file to log you
out when you log in with SSH
not an issue Bandit
what I want to do is
probably we can inject command in SSH
now let's see let's go to man SSH and
not aware man command not found
let's go to SSH tap tag help
and here we can see command argument it
is specified inside this braces not
braces these brackets
so probably what I can do is
SSH pass and then I can simply write
over here LS and that would probably do
the job
yes it has showed readme
if I do cat
read me over here
so
if we give
commands like this
we have received the password over here
that's great
so this is how we can inject command not
inject command this is this is not a
vulnerability anyways this is a
uh intentionally feature that has been
added that whenever connection is made
we can run the commands real quick
so LS gave us the content and cat readme
gave us this
let's do some more fun just like this
let's do LS plus la
LS minus l a
and we'll be getting all those things
anyway so this is for level
uh
19.
so Echo this level 19
let's move ahead to level 19 right now
and let's see what we have for us
waiting
so in level 19 to gain access the next
level you should be you should use the
set uid binary because we have to tackle
with the set uid binary files in the
home directory executed without
arguments to find out how to use it the
password for the for for this level we
found in the usual place this
after you have used the set UD binary
file I have by mistake I have used this
commands over here
for which I am not being able to
coincide okay so we are inside Bandit
19.
there's a set uid binary file what the
set uid binary file and how to recognize
that if you see the file permissions
real quick there is s present s stands
for set uid binary file what that means
is
that this file is having the privilege
of Bandit 20 but this file is
can be executed or can this file can be
run like Bandit 19 can run this file and
this file has the permission of value 20
so
for the time being Bandit 19 will be
getting the access of Bandit 20's
privilege
so the time taken to run this particular
set uid binary file for that amount of
time when did 19 will have the privilege
of value 20 so we will be using or we
will be taking the taking the advantage
of this particular good news or good
feature
so it's a binary file so I'll be using
dot slash Bandit 20 do hit enter and it
says run a command as another user and
it says ID
so if I say ID it will of course show my
ID because I am running it but of course
it will show
or give me leverage of Bandit 20 so if I
do
cat
let's see
Bandit pass Bandit 20 now since
Bandit 19 is actually seeing the content
of 2020 so this is not actually
permitted but when since I am watching
the content or seeing the content of
Bandit 20 using the binary file so I
will be getting the privilege of mandate
20 and hence I can what oh it's a
spelling mistake and hence I can
actually view the content of Bandit 20.
so this is the password what I have did
is I've given an underscore over here
rather I have to give a
slash
so this is the password of Bandit 20.
let's go and solve when did 20. let's
see what do we get
SSH pass switch to Bandit 20.
there's a set you already modified in
the home directory that does the
following it makes a connection to the
localhost on the port you specify as a
command line argument it then reads a
line of a text from the connection and
Compares with the password previous
level
if the password is curve it will
transmit the possible the next level
Monday 21 okay so I have understood what
I have to do let me make you understand
what I have to do but before that
I have to open another terminal over
here another instance of my Linux
shell and I have to SSH into
Bandit 20 once again
so let me
go inside Bandit 20.
now I'm inside band 20 let me just scat
out the password of ben20
this is the password and let me
copy the password and keep it in my
clipboard because I need it what this
challenge is saying that there will be
uh let me first go over here and
clear this terminal out LS there's a
binary file known as Su connect what
this will do is if I execute it
it will tell me that usage dot slash Su
connect and then a port number so it
will establish a connection into that
port and what we need to do we have to
establish this or we have to connect to
that same port and through the second
shell we have to send the password of
the current user and and this finite
file will compare the password of valid
20 with the password that we have
supplied if that matches then only it
will send me the password of Bandit 21.
so the way we will do it
I will first establish a netcat listener
over here so NC minus l v p l stands for
listen v stands for verbose verbose will
give me all the output all the back end
output and all P stands for Port support
Let It Be triple I mean four twos not
triple two four twos
and over here first let me start the
connection let me start the instant so
it says listening on Port
two two two double two double two so dot
Su connect so it will establish a
connection on two two two two and
whatever will happen on this particular
Port we can see this on this netcat
listener just over here if I hit enter
you can see the
this is a prompt right over here and
there is it says connection received on
localhost
44064 now I have to paste the password
over here and if I hit enter it gives us
a new password but over here it says red
the password that we have supplied
uh let me
okay
the password you have supplied and it
says we have read the password that we
have supplied and password matches
sending next password and we have got
the next password over here
so
I'll be copying the password
let's hit exit because that's not our
use
let's save the password of Bandit 21
and let me close it from here as well
and let's go ahead and switch
the user to mandate21
a program is running automatically at
regular intervals from Quran okay so we
are having or we have to deal with
chrome jobs again if we're not sure what
cron Jobs means prawn is a Time
scheduler kind of thing that means if we
have something to do at this amount of
time and you want to do it automatically
you can set a crown job it's time of a
you can say it's a time-based job
scheduler look into hcron.d for the
configuration and see what command is
being executed okay we will be having
fun with prawn jobs let's see LS of
course we find nothing so let's go to HC
and cron.d folder LS we find lots of
jobs over here
but we are interested in Bandit 22 that
is running right over here
so if I do LS minus L A Cron job Bandit
22 is a file which I can understand by
seeing that it is preceded with minus or
a hyphen which states that it's a file
so I'll do cat
then Crone job Bandit 22
hit enter it says at the rate reboot
Bandit 22 this particular file actually
this particular shelf file is getting
executed
and it is getting executed at each and
every hour minute days month like that
so
star means wild card if you don't know
so let's
let us go ahead into this directory real
quick just to see what is actually
happening or rather what we can do is
we can cut out the content probably Ctrl
shift C
it there's a bash file it says chmod 644
temp and this file
cat
Etsy Bandit pass Bandit 22 and redirects
it to this file
so what we can understand is first it is
changing the permission of this
particular folder
and then it is saving the password into
this particular folder
so we can go ahead and we can go inside
this particular folder
hit enter
uh it says it's not a direct okay it's
it is a file I guess
is it a file yes it's a file
uh
trying to get get this file and we have
got the password over here
so this is a file inside temp folder
which it has created if you are confused
what I have actually done
let me
solve the solution for you once again so
there's a crown job Bandit 22. we are
interested in getting the password of
Bandit 22 and Let's ignore this 23 24
and all those things
so since these are files so let's see
what these are doing what are the
scripts written so there's a script that
is getting executed which is over here
so let's see what is the content of that
particular script
so
that is a shell script which you can see
over here that hashtag or shebang and
then exclamation mark then slash bin
slash bash CH mode it's changing the
permission of this particular file and
Cat it is cutting out or taking the
password Bandit 22 and setting it or
redirecting or rather saving the
password or storing the password in this
particular file so what we have done we
have copied the file name we have simply
went cat
and we have hit enter and read it how
can we
like how did we get to understand that
that we can actually read the file
because of the permission 644 I said
Force means read so everybody can read
at six means there is two permission
read and write that is four and two so
the user that has created this
particular file can both read and write
and rest of the world and the groups can
read it so we have we are having the
read permission
so we can read the file
and we can copy it we can exit out of it
Echo
this is for level 22.
let's go ahead
and
let's go and solve Bandit 22.
it says that a program is running
automatically at regular intervals from
cron the time based job scheduler look
in FC granted for the configuration and
see what command is being executed look
at the shell script written by other
people is a very useful skill the script
for this level is intentionally made
easy to read if you are having problem
understanding what it does try executing
it see the debug information it prints
so let's go to First Etsy chron.d and
since we are logged in as Bandit 22 so
we are interested in Bandit 23
so Cat Run job Bandit 23 and we can see
the shell script that is being
executed is this so let's copy it let's
get it
[Music]
it says hashtag dollar hashtag
exclamation mark win bash my name and
then this now since it is being
run by user Bandit 23 so who am I will
give us band 23 so my name equals to
Bandit 23 my target is equals to Echo I
am user when the 23
taking it giving it as md5 sum
okay
copying the password file let's see
Bandit password my name that is Bandit
23 so copying HC when it pass
2023 is to temp and then the file name
over here my target
cat HC Bandit 23 it is Echo okay the cat
hc2023 to my target okay
so what this is actually doing is
my name is equals to who am I so in this
case who am I will be Bandit 23
my target
is equals to
Echo I am user my name so Echo
I am user Bandit 23
and it is being passed to md5 sum so it
is being encrypted into md5 algorithm
and then they are using cut command so
what will actually happen is if I do not
give like this
so there is a minus sign right over here
so to remove this minus sign they're
using this command cut command
if I also give
okay uh
md5 some if I also give this and hit
enter I'll be getting this file name
over here
this md5 sum
if I copy it and they are storing this
thing into a variable called my Target
and that's what they're saying that cat
HC Bandit
when the 23 the password of only 23 is
restored into temp my target so if I go
to CD slash temp slash
my target
uh not CD since they're getting it so
it's a
file
it will be get
and here is the password
so let's
save the password real quick and this is
for 23.
great
let's go to level 23 let's see what do
we have
waiting for us no more Crown please I'm
tired of it
oh again some Crown jobs okay so our
program is running automatically at
regular intervals from cron the time was
job scheduler look in this for
configuration and super command is being
executed same thing this level requires
you to create your own first shell
script okay so this is a very big step
and you should be proud of yourself when
you beat this level
Note 2 keep in mind that your shell
script is removed once executed so you
may want to keep a copy around
all right
let's see
CD HC slash cron.d this is the folder
where all the Chrome jobs are listed and
we are interested in Bandit 24 since we
are logged in as 2023
so get cron jobs Bandit 24.
and the shell script that is being
executed is this
let's read the shell script
and it says again Bandit 24
it is going inside where spool my name
and Foo my name will be of course there
when did 24.
it is doing for i n
star dot star so whatsoever file name
with whatsoever extension
do if file name not equals to Dot and
file name not equals to dot dot so if
the file name is not a hidden file or
not a hidden directory then
uh I'm not sure what this is doing
stat minus one is format percent dude or
slash
so basically what I can understand is
it is kind of executing the file
after 60 seconds because time out
you can see minus s for seconds I don't
know what 9 means but 60 seconds and Dot
slash dollar rise so whatsoever file is
present inside where spool
2024 Foo the files present inside there
are ones executed each 60 second and
then they are being removed
and it is being executed by Bandit 24 so
we can actually see the password of
value 24.
great so I am having a very fishy idea
and I think that's what they want us to
do to create your own first shell script
so I'll be going inside CD where spool
they say it banded 24.
if I do LS I get to see Foo over here I
don't know whether you can see or not
whoops
go to Foo not fool sorry fool
of course I cannot do LS
I need to make a file so let's do Nano
and suppose the file is give
me pass DOT sh
and inside that I have to write a
hashtag exabang
dollar slash Win slash pairs just to
know that we are writing a bash file and
I will be redirecting at HC Bandit pass
slash Bandit 24 password to
foreign
I might
have trouble doing this
because I'm not having any folder
created by default so what can happen is
if I close it right now and before
actually making the file
let me go to the temp folder and make a
directory so that I can receive the
password
so mkdir
game 255
CD cam 255 whatsoever
and now I'll be going to this where
pool
Bandit 24
who and then I'll be making a script
over here pass DOT sh
and then I'll be writing
slash bin slash bash
cat let's see
then when that pass and I do not have so
much of time because it is going to
execute every 60 Seconds
Bandit 24 and save it inside a tab
folder inside game 255
as a file name pass underscore received
and the spelling is wrong which we
shouldn't be care about caring about
Ctrl X
y
and before hitting enter the file name
is pass.sh so chmod
777
uh pass DOT sh dot list
give me this
time uh sorry
date
it's 55 so after 5 Seconds we should be
getting our file if I do LS
temp
and before that let me do date and of
course 60 has
been passed away not passed away passed
sorry and if I go to LS over here real
quick temp
cam 255
we have got nothing
that's weird
probably we were
late
am I having
the pass.sh again it's 46 over here are
we having
this file
pass.sh no we don't
or rather we have we don't know I know
pass DOT sh
we do not have that
so I have to make it once again
and please get let's see
Slash Bandit
underscore pass slash
Bandit 24 redirect it
to them
game 255 under name pass received
and Ctrl X Y enter CH mode 777 to pass
DOT sh
to pass DOT sh and let me see the time
is 53 let's wait for seven seconds till
then let's go to Temp and game 255 we
have nothing current over here
so
we have nothing
that's
pretty strange
we are having nothing
according to it
it should be executed and we have given
execution permission as 777 this should
have been deleted after executing
but I don't know why it is not getting
executed
rather if I go to get HC
bend it pass
Bandit
23 so I'll be getting the password
so let me keep a copy of it
real quick
so what I can do is I can make a file
over here
before that
let me copy the whole thing
Nano pass DOT sh
ape
bin Bash
in this one 24 and save it
and TMP
foreign
slash
password 24
.
LS pass.sh is there LS minus l a
we have to give read write permission
so if I do s minus La it is having a
read write permission now I am going to
we have lots of time so I'm going to
copy this
pass.sh into
where
tool
Bandit 24
who
and if I check date
it's 42 if I do LS
slash VAR slash spool
and then bend it full and then pass DOT
sh it's present over here
and it has already been executed
but for some reason we are not getting
the file
and that's a very strange I don't know
what's wrong
with this
if I send the password file the shell
file once again and if I
do LS minus L A it is having read write
permissions
and if I do date
we're having much more time right now
so this should have been working
I'm not sure why it isn't
and it should be working
come on please work
and it is not
working
that's great and it has been deleted as
well so let's
see what wrong am I actually doing
let's go and read the source file once
again
what I realized real quick over here
that one thing that I was doing wrong
that
my
this particular folder that is game 25
is not actually
having the permission to receive any
kind of files because it is not having
that
permission to receive files or to modify
the like due to the file permission
issues we are actually facing this
problem so what I want to do is
chmod 777 I'm giving read write execute
permission to this particular folder it
is game 255
and then if I see the
game two five five and then if I
send this
what is that time
uh I don't know where that thing is
there it is
copy and for that let me see okay
we have already passed the time
CP pass DOT sh to where it's full value
242 if ice
send it over there and if I do LS minus
l a
inside that pass DOT a is present in
that spool folder spool value 24 4 so
it's having read write execute and
probably this time we will be getting
the file and it's 37 let's wait for
this to become 60
then we might receive our password file
so if I give date it's 54 let's do LS
nothing nothing
[Music]
and here we received our password 24
file that's great
so due to those file permission issues
we were not been able
to
[Music]
get the content that means that script
was actually sending the password 24
file but we were not being able to
receive it due to some file permission
issues
so silly me I was not aware of it Ctrl
shift C
exit it and Echo
save it to
24.
let's go to 24.
a demon is listening on Port
3002 and will give you the password for
Value 25 if given the password for 2024
and a secret memory 4 digit PIN code
there is no way to retrieve the PIN code
especially except by going through all
of the Thousand combination called Brute
forcing
what does that even mean
let's see
24 24.
LS anything nope
shall we go to HC prawn.d
anything
they say 25 underscore root
uh Damon is listening on Port
thirty thousand two
okay
all right this is not related to cron
that I have understood
let me clear it out
if I do NC and
local
host and try to connect on 30
000 to
I am a pin code checker for using a
bandit 25 please enter the password for
us for user value 24 and secret pin code
on a single line separated by a space
that means if the password is
or rather if I give the password
and one one one one
oops
it is having a timing as well what the
hell
one one one one it says wrong presented
the correct PIN code
one two three four
wrong again okay
so we need to do a Brute Force that's
great
so the way we can do it of course by
using for Loop so for i n
zero zero zero zero it's a four
combination two nine nine nine nine
and do what I am trying to do is
do Echo
[Music]
dollar right
done
and I am
not echoed all right I will be saying
Echo the password and then dollar I
done and whenever you will make the
combinations
send it to NC on localhost at Port
thirty thousand two and do not
Echo this thing it is much more
hazardous
Echo me Dollar this and actually perform
this particular operations with dollar I
so what I have done is let me make you
understand real quick for I n000 to 9999
four zeros to four nine so it will make
a combination of zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero one zero zero zero two
and so on till nine nine nine nine and
on each iterations the value of uh the
value will be stored in this variable I
so I have said do during each iterations
it will show me the value of I that is
the first iteration to show me zero zero
zero zero one or second iteration like
that and it need to perform
an operation give this
the password and then dollar I so dollar
I means the value will be stored and
I'll be taking the whole output and
since I am using a pi operator I'll be
taking the whole output and sending it
to NC localhost this so what this will
happen now is a magic if I hit enter
did not supply enough data did we fail
we shouldn't
what the hell is that
well
what
command not found
great
that was that what I was expecting
I can do Echo and then can I do is it
fifty thousand two
a demon is listening localhost let's hit
enter
oh we got it
fail you did not supply enough data
whatsoever the password for the user
Bandit 25 is
this
great
so let me just copy it and why it was
showing uh please uh you did not supply
enough data because
this was being sent dollar I so only the
PIN code was been sent but this demon
needed two parameters that is the
password of the current level and then
the part and then the PIN code
so if I remove this thing
if I remove this dollar
to go from here and if I simply do like
this
it will say please enter the correct pin
code try again and then the cut and then
the password the user 25 is this
great
let's copy it perfectly
[Music]
Echo and store it on 25.
let's go and have a look on challenge
25 was waiting for us
logging into Bandit 26 from 2025 should
be fairly easy the shell for Value 26 is
not wind bash but something else
find out what is it and how it works and
how to break out of it
so we are in 2025
LS
bandit26.sh key so SSH
minus I the identifier name
the username is Bandit 26 at the rate
localhost minus p2220
hit enter click on yes I mean it says
connection to localhost closed
it says the shell for user value 26 is
not Bash
what shell is being used by Bandit 25
bin Bash
let's go
and see
cat HC pass WD file
to offer
gibberish written
grab Bandit
26
it is using using show text
so what we can do is
user bin show text can I see cat
user bin
short text
oh
okay looks like a shell command export
term equals to Linux
execute more
parent text of txt I don't know what
that means text Dot txt is it
the banner that they're printing
probably I have no idea
is it this Banner because it is
different from what we have
like it is different from this manner
probably I do not know so what we can do
is
there is even more
can we do anything with more I haven't
used more since long time let's see what
do we get over here
can we execute commands using more oh we
have got something by the way
V is used to start up an editor
specifically VI or Vim Okay so
environment shell okay
let's do one thing what more actually
does it if I could give you a good
example
if I go CD over here do I have some name
let's make a file touch
file Dot dxt and let's run a loop for
ien
zero zero zero to
for example 555
to
Echo dollar I
and
file
Dot txt
done
and if I just get
file.txt you can see all the numbers are
over here but what more will do is
if I show it to you like this
and if I write more
and then file.txt it will give us a
prompt till here and we can use the down
arrow key to navigate you can see I am
using the down arrow key
to see the content and then it says end
so it is giving us a prompt over here
and that's what we will be using right
now
so
if I do this thing once again
if I give yes
probably I have to make the screen much
bigger or the text much bigger
whatsoever I do doesn't matter
that's it let's give yes
I have to make the screen much
smaller I have understood
can you exploit it
okay so you can see we have got
something like this
oops
again
we have got a stop and then I will be
pressing V
so I am inside the whim shell
let me keep it like this
and let me
minimize it
I'm inside vimp
now do not write how to exit when I will
be showing you not worry for that
uh
probably it's it's too
set if I could zoom it for you
shelf is equals to
bin
Bash
and
like this unknown option shell
okay
I have forward beam as well
I mean this was
can you write like that no we cannot
yes I know whether I'm insert mode
um S2 oh we have somehow entered into
insert mode
and I don't want that
how to exit with or how to not exit them
how to
take
Bim
out of
insert mode
hit Escape okay Escape okay so it is and
if I hit I it is in insert mode if I hit
Escape it is in normal mode
great
actually not whim it was VI
how to set
variables in VI
yeah it was is to set
this to
said
show reports to open Bash
and then again is to
shell probably
let's see
this to Let Her Go
alright so I believe
we are facing certain problems guess
what
uh let me try that once again
uh if I do like this since it is using
more so we should be stopped over here
hit V so we are in Vim right now
let's just wise not maximize at least
let's
set it over here
and
in a proper size
is to R to read a file that is HC
slash Bandit
underscore pass
slash Bandit 26
is to R stands for reading a file
warning changing read-only file please
enter a type command to continue enter
and yes over here we have received
the file uh the password Ctrl shift C
of level 26 and how to quit
is to
Q
underscore
hopefully
nope
yeah what is that yeah it's done
hopefully it's done I don't know but
it's too underscore Cube Maybe
let's see how to do it S2 underscore
queue oops sorry
S2 underscore Q
or s2q
yeah it's too cute whatsoever doesn't
matter
let's exit out of it and Echo this is
the password that we have
got and this is of 26 that was an
interesting thing
I didn't use Vim or VI for so long
actually I don't use so often
since I've got Visual Studio Sublime
Text and many other cool text editors
but that connection to Bandit layers are
closed what
and why is that so let's go to level 26
and let's see what challenges we have
again
good job getting a shell now hurry up
and grab the password for Bandit 27.
oh I forgot that 2026 is not using bash
it is using short text or something like
that
can I use command over here like LS
what
foreign
that is none of our use
uh go good job getting a shell now hurry
and grab the password for Bandit 27 come
on you may need to solve this level is
LS interesting thing is how to get
inside this value 26 what we can do is
if I go inside
Bandit 25
let's clear it out
let's search for the word command
so there are various ways we can
use command and Bim
is there any word for a shell
so what we can do is
we can do the same stuff
foreign
and since it is using more it should
stop and I am using V over here
and now
it
should be fine and now I'll be using S2
set
shell is equals to Bent
slash Bash
and once it is set
hello
okay so it is set now I'll be using H2
shell
and we have got a real shell over here
red
so
if I do which bash you can see we are
using user win Bash
so we have actually set the variables in
like previously I was giving capital
letter variable but over here we had to
give small letters so that was working
if I do LS we got Bandit 27 do
so dot slash Bandit 27 do
run command as another user so
simply get HC Bandit pass and Bandit 27
and we will be getting the password for
when it level 27 that's great
let's exit out of it
uh let's close it it's to Q
it's closed
or closed
what's that
exit
Echo
as 27 and now let's go to Bandit
27 user
and let's see what do we have in level
27
there's a git repository at this
location the password for the value 27
git is same as the user bunny 27 clone
the repository and find the password for
the next level
clone the repository that means I have
to go inside
temp
make dir
game
one two three
CD game one two three
and let's do git clone
of this repo
and hopefully this report exists I don't
know hit enter
yes
what
permission denied
you are trying to log into the server on
Port 22 what that means even I'm just
if I do CH mod 777 and then game one two
three is that fine
what the hell
please make sure you have the correct
access rights and the repository exists
what the hell that even means permission
denied
could not read from remote Repository
that's one big issue and I don't know
what to do
but I can do one thing as
since I am not getting the permission so
what I want to do is
I'm using another
comma that is Mac temp so it will make a
temporary folder in the temp directory
and
hopefully it was this I don't remember
so this folder has been created for me
so if I go inside this folder and then
if I do get clone
and then
SSH
okay repo
and hit enter
oops
sorry
this says problem again and you're
trying to log into the server on 422
which is not intended
and it says please make sure that you
have quite access right which I do have
but also the repository exists which I'm
not sure but I don't know what why this
is being shown to me
get at the red localhost shall I
do something like localhost
is 22220
yes finally we have
solve this so local levels are there two
to zero value 27's password
what is the password of 2027 that
OTW Bandit
27
so
let's paste it hit enter
and we have received
CD repo so cdrepo LS readme
get
readme the password to the next level is
this
okay
so exit
Echo this
Next Level that is 28 great
let's go to level 28 and I think this
has been changed recently because I have
seen many write-ups and many other
Solutions and walkthroughs in nowhere
I have actually got the solution that I
was facing
but I have a regret it cracked it and
I'm happy for that
let's go to level 28 it says there's a
git repository at this
so let me copy copy it
before that make
temp
minus d
slash temp slash TMP
Dot
j u f g v
n g
o g e probably
and inside that
get clone this and after localhost
just add the port number 2220 and hit
enter
click on yes
it asks for the password of level 28
let's see
take this password
paste it over here
we have got repo CD repo LS
that
[Music]
readme.md we have got
uh if I look at redmi.amd it says that
supports for level 29 credentials and
password is hidden
we have get installed red
and are we having the git folder
Target yes
so that means we can see the combats
that has been made
so get comment
sorry I mean
commits I believe
I don't know what was the
come on let's see the get
uh what to say those are
cheat sheet
let's open that
uh
okay so I was Finding for logs so git
log
so it says add missing data so here's a
commit
so copy and get
check out probably let's go ahead and
see
where is that
yeah great checkout
and then the comment name hit enter
and then if I do cat
read V
I will be getting the password
so you can say what I have done is or
rather I would suggest you to go ahead
and learn get basically I have searched
for the logs so the user has get first
of all is a Version Control System okay
so git logs gives me the logs that the
number of time the particular file has
been changed the readme.md file has been
changed and these are the some tokens
you can say some identifiers and I have
used this and I said that show me what
changes you have done on this particular
identifier and
at that point of time they have removed
this text and have entered XXL and all
those things
so this is the password so hit exit
Echo this and save it to level
29.
now let's go to level 29 real quick
level 29
states that there's a good report
repository at this
the password for the Bandit 19 is same
clone the repository and find the
password for the next level
let me clear all these things
make temp minus D and I'm not going to
copy this and I know that when I'll be
copying this
my repository clip will be replaced so
CD
go inside this and just simply git blown
this thing
Ctrl shift C
oops
Ctrl C and Ctrl shift
V over here
it will ask me for the password for sure
and
it's 29
click on yes
[Music]
oh sorry what I have done a mistake that
I did not add the port
click on yes the password I've pasted
received CD Ripple
we have got
we have got a readme.md no password in
production
tell me what are the branches present is
master and what are the branches present
it's Dev master and sportsdev
good
luck
fix username
initial comment of readme
no password in production
if I open the cheat sheet
get
check out
Dev
I and here we have got the password of
Bandit 30.
so what I've done is they said that
no password in production so it was in
the master bronze that means you can say
it as a main branch but when I did minus
r it showed me the several
branches as well there was Dev Masters
plus Dev so Dev stands for development
so if it is not in production it is in
development phase so I said that git
checkout and then Dev so I want to visit
that Dev branch that development branch
and they said that switched oops
switch to a new Branch Tab and then I
did LS to see what are the folders
present in that Branch folders and files
so when I did get readme I got the file
this
so it was interesting
Echo this to 30
let's switch from user 29 to user 30.
there's a git repository clone the
repository and find the password of text
level
uh Mac temp minus d
go to this particular folder
and get clown
this particular repo
Ctrl C Ctrl shift V
and in localhost
press 2220
let me copy it go over here give the
permission give the password hit enter
clear LS CD repo
LS cat
[Music]
cat
readme.md just an empty file okay
good
laws not logs log
initial comment
this
which is actually this
get branch
there's a head branch and a master
branch
what can I do
so what we can do is if I see over here
will not get
any other things
uh if I do LS minus L A and if I go to
CD
dot get
we get many things and if I do LS minus
r
probably
we will be saying many many things
which is kind of confusing
if I get out description
nothing
get config
nothing get index
index
it's nothing
get head
nothing as well
if we go to CD info
good exclude
of course nothing
and if we go inside CD logs
get ahead
nothing we get
CD refs do we get anything
if I go to hooks
the things we get over here do we have
tags and get I don't know
if I if we are actually having tags
or something like that get dance
can you tag someone because when I was
having your Oktoberfest when I
participated in that hacktoberfest over
there there's something called a stag
but in the cheat sheet there is nothing
for us tags
so yeah so git tag will list all the
tags out there
so
get tag so there's a tag called a secret
okay that's fine
how to
C tag
git show and then tag okay git show
secret and
hopefully that's the password for
the next
level
which is
31
so let's see
let's go to level 31.
this says there's a git repository at
this
okay
foreign
directory
and in this
directory Take Me In
I want to do a git clone but before that
give me the password of this one
great
and
foreign
hit enter
yes I have copied the password already
it's done CD repo
cat read me let's get
readme
may I come in master file in the time
your talk is to push a file in a remote
Repository
okay
master so
let's make a file
Echo
may I come in
and keep it in key Dot dxt
there's a key.txt out there
and
there's a git ignore file as well let's
go ahead and read that git ignore file
so it says any file that comes in dot
txt will be ignored so I have to remove
this otherwise if I push this key.txt
into the master Branch this will be
deleted
so Nano Dot
get ignore
and I have to remove this
Ctrl X so I enter
so now if I do cat getting no nothing is
there
or I could have just removed the git
ignore file as well
RM get ignore
simply remove it
and then I think get
commit
ad probably
uh get add okay so get
add key Dot txt
get
can you see the status
[Music]
yes new file has been edged added it is
in unstaged manner so we have to Stage
it
so let's commit
get commit minus M let's give a message
I don't know what to give
let's simply get commit
what is that
I have to give a message right
okay
added key Dot dxt
one file change create mode key.txt and
now
get push
remote Branch Okay so
what if I do only get push
it requires the Branded 31 localhost
password
V yeah I am already having it
that space the password
it
failed and welder and here is the
password for the next level okay we have
done it
so let's copy it
exit and Echo
this is probably the password of level
32.
hold on it was 31 right yeah
level 32 so let's get ahead and let's
solve when did level 32.
let's see what is there in level 32.
after all this good stuff it's time for
another Escape good luck
welcome to uppercase shell that means LS
what the hell is that LS hello
not found
LS not found what the hell man
okay
so
it is using
bone shell over here probably
it is not a normal bash shell
it's
it's born shells that's b-o-u-r-n-e
World shell
uh I don't know what to write
commands
these are only those things
one shell manual
and it is taking two arguments
okay
so after reading this manual what I can
find is what if I press Ctrl C of course
the connection will be closed
and what I've understood that whatever
commands I'll be writing it is getting
converted to
uppercase
that means it is somewhat related to uh
positional arguments
which I found
somewhere over here
regarding all this you can see parameter
substitution and command substitution so
in this parameter substitution
if I give
dollar uh zero let's see what do we get
we get a shell over here if I do LS we
get upper shell you can see and if I say
which batch
rather which
bash it says we are in user user bin
bash so we have got a shell over here A
bash shell and now we can do cat and
let's see Bandit underscore pass
and this is not an interactive shell
this is just a normal shell and Bandit
it is I think 32 and we need a password
for 33
33
probably
53 can we do so yes
so here is the password for Bandit 13 3.
so let's
go ahead and
Echo
this to 33
let's try it and said
and sit over here and Ctrl C
33
no such file seriously
no search File oh
OTW
Bandit and then 33 and remove 33 from
here
and remove file.txt from here which I've
made to show you how to
mess with the more command
let's go to level 33 which is the last
one
at this moment level 34 doesn't exist
LS
I don't know what to say LS readme.txt
cat green winner txt it says
congratulations on solving the last
level of this game at this moment there
are no more levels to play in this game
however we are constantly working on new
levels and will most likely to expand
this game with more levels soon keep it
now keep an eye out for announcement on
a usual communication channels in this
meantime you could paste some other War
Games if you have an idea or some
readable please let us know all right
so this is the official end of the
Bandit war game
and post it or
uh hosted by over the wire a big big
shout out and thank you for over the
wire to launch such a great
war game which has taught many of you
including me even after solving
bandwidth and after solving or after
being in cyber security still we're
bandit has been proven very helpful for
me in refreshing on all those in
revising my Basics and of course I
believe it has helped you in
in getting your feet wet and giving you
a very good in uh what to say a very
good glance of how tall you should be
with your basics so this was a beginner
friendly room and
hopefully you have learned a lot from
this room and see you guys on the next
one with another video and till then
have a great day and goodbye